how's the gum resumes we're back with
pure duck pie probably the worst game
the best game ever cuz I'm in it oh [ __ ]
I got a lot of tips from you bros about
how to complete that [ __ ] [ __ ] and
hopefully now we can come [ __ ] alright I
got it
alright what he's trying to look up
about my skirt that's what he's trying
to do [ __ ] be thirsty oh go go go go go
go go go go go go go yes
yes come on baby alright wait for the
green light then jump come on oh oh oh
that was kind of obvious wasn't it
Pokemon nerd user brain who would win
squirrel versus shame any shame in go to
the one you think would win well he
they're both on meth I don't think
anyone would win they would just
probably [ __ ] each other go chairman a
that's rat [ __ ]
wrong squirrel would win water is
stronger than fire now jump into the
portal and go left please
alright go left why would I go left
alright then check whine [ __ ]
yes ah
you tricked me what are you doing I just
want to say so you don't won't get hurt
take the fish and bring it to me hehe
yes go oh shut up
Oh God why is everything on meth stop it
shame on you oh god I gotta get that
fish come on fish I don't have no
quarrel with you but I have to go there
we go my people are calling me oh he
died yes haha yeah alright that was hard
don't you know don't let me do the fish
part again the fish part sucks
you know maybe fighting away this
beautiful skirt people wouldn't be going
after my anus go go go go there we go
you're dead everyone on this game is on
meth except me I'm on fab
oh my god it's so hard you little but
what God is so disgusting
go away hey man my mum my mama's Coco
jump victor shun come on come out come
on Timmy I hate him no oh
demons made this game oh don't
down here we go
I got you now but my no more Oh fine yes
yes all right I got it I got it
we got it there we go I'm a duck this
shouldn't even be a problem to begin
with
all right what do i do by you come on
beats not a batch what the [ __ ]
what I don't trust you all right you
didn't want to [ __ ] with me don't you
know I'm a blood that's your job bla bla
bla
how do I get past many sauces yeah
Rita come here come here yes all right
eye out smarted him now how do I go this
huh no no no no no no what what was that
I can jump on him oh my god Sam
that didn't make any sense Oh minecraft
man
Oh minecraft man Oh might feel thank red
minecraft
all right all right you gotta trick him
all right and then you go and then you
jump on that batch ah that is good yeah
mm-hmm all right all right don't touch
yeah yeah yeah met in quarter fifth mini
Cola fix that right now
ha ha all right all right now I don't
understand it just go what ha what what
what [ __ ] what is happening what was
that why what is happening what is that
all right what English
no there's a spare guy was always a
spare guy is it a mess soft on me but
Lenny Irvin he'll bet this job la mouche
Kaka mapa thought this awesome
I hate this game I really do did it have
to start with the fish part was that
really necessary
you're cutting that bit like you know
what maybe this game shouldn't have a
future part that's just an idea for
future games this part I cannot do it
it's kind
I just sighs I should feel that's
motherland don't grab my anus thank you
that's very it's a gentleman
anyone that has more than five chins is
a gentleman that is the rules I don't
understand this part I don't I really
don't don't kill me
all right mate Oh mate thank you [ __ ]
Mendon oh I don't have feelings anymore
Oh small capitán [ __ ] can soar chance
then all right now stop stop I'm gonna
complete this vulgar level if it's the
last thing I'll ever do Oh had a huge or
how did I do
don't call for my don't don't do it
don't do it it's budding plants you're
gonna be this fat satisfied with the
product god damn it all right all right
enough of the tricks I'm not gonna fall
hey deciding game is so [ __ ] much I
hate this video [ __ ] it makes me want to
become a duck [ __ ] this piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] it all pay a so [ __ ] much
[ __ ] this [ __ ] game
just wait for the right moment wait for
a right moment
wait for that moment that's the right
moment okay wha what what is that
Oh God that's hot I'm not even supposed
to be here alright [ __ ]
Oh nope nope nope nope nope enough
enough
all right edge guys take it off my
channel [ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]